ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
นักเรียน
ใส่ครูหญิงวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันศุกร์
ค่ะวันนี้วันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
1 ค่ะวันที่ 1 เดือนอะไรเดือน
เมษายนเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะมีผช
2565 ค่ะ
ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะดีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแต่
ตอนนี้เวลา
16:00 น 48 นาทีค่ะ
4 โมง 48 นาที้
[เพลง]
คู่แข่งอะไร
แข่งวาดรูปค่ะว่าเกิดผู้
ครูเอ๋ต้องมีไวท์บอร์ดหรอคะห้องค่ะครูเอ๋
ไม่ต้องมีไม่ว่าที่ไวท์บอร์ดอย่างนี้เหรอ
อ๋ออ๋อว่าของครูหญิงไม่ได้เดี๋ยวครู
หญิง Share  screen ค่ะครูเอ๋โอเคค่ะ
[เพลง]
อ๋อผู้หญิง Share  screen
ขอครูหญิง
เลือกสีก่อนนะคะครูเอ๋ได้ค่ะผู้หญิงปากกา
สีอะไรคะผู้หญิงปากกาสีน้ำเงินค่ะผู้หญิง
สีน้ำเงินงั้นของครูเอ๋สีสีอะไรคะครูเอ๋
สีเขียว OK ไหม ok
เสือครูผู้หญิงสีน้ำเงินครูเอ๋สีสีเขียว
รสกันค่ะสีเขียว
[เพลง]
เดี๋ยวนะคะอันนี้
ครูเอ๋
ขยายครูก่อนค่ะลืม
ครูเอ๋นะคะ
ผู้หญิงค่ะเย็บที่อยากไวท์บอร์ดเปิดไม่
ได้ได้ไหมครูหญิงขยายได้ไหมคะขยายได้ค่ะ
สิ่งขยับไวท์บอร์ดนิดนึงค่ะ
โอเคได้แล้ว
ครูเอ๋สีสีเขียวผู้หญิงสีน้ำเงินชัยขาดนะ
คะคุณเอ๋วาดแค่นี้
มาหากูอีกว่านิดหน่อยนะคะ
ถึงทั้งหมดว่าได้แค่นี้ค่ะ
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงแล้วนะคะอ่า
คู๋ว่าเท่าไหร่นะไม่ทั้งหมดนะคะทางบทใช้
ในรูปอ่อยว่าถึงเส้นสีน้ำเงินออโอเคเพราะ
ว่าเอ่อคุยอิ๋ง
คู๋ว่าวาด
วัดตรงนี้ใช่ไหม
จ่ายค่ะว่าได้เนี่ยตรงนี้ช้างหมดลงนี้ว่า
ได้โอนเส้นสีน้ำเงินได้ค่ะได้เข้าใจเข้า
ใจ
นี่มากกว่าเดี๋ยวพี่เอาเส้นสีแดงแล้วกัน
นะคะ
พี่เก๋แก
เป่ายิงฉุบใครวาดก่อนเน้อ
เนื้อเพลง
กรรไกรกันเอ้ยป๋องสาม
กระดาษถาดกระดาษเอาไว้เด้อ
เอาอีกหนึ่งสองสาม
เอาใหม่ 1  2  3
ออกก่อนครูเอ๋ยังออกเหมือนกันไว้อีก 1
ครั้ง
หนึ่งสองสาม
โอเคคู๋อะไรนครผู้หญิงกระดาษหุ้มขอนผู้
หญิงชนะครูเอ๋วาดก่อนค่ะ
ผู้หญิงชนะกูเอกวาดก่อนนะคะให้ค่ะฮะโอเค
นะกูอีกว่าก่อนเดี๋ยวสักครู่นะคะคุณ
เลื่อนก่อนได้ค่ะนักเรียนดูครูเอ๋จะวาด
อะไร
ครูเอ๋วาด
ขู่เขาค่ะผู้หญิงอ๋อโครเอวาดภูเขา
ภูเขาค่ะ
คู๋วัดภูเขาอ่ะผู้หญิงคู๋มีภูเขาพวกเขา
ใหญ่ไปไหมผู้หญิงใหญ่ไปเนาะเอาตัวเองคุย
เอาเล็กๆดีกว่าได้ค่ะคุยวาดเล็กๆก็ได้ค่ะ
ภูเขาลูกเล็กๆอะกูเองวาดภูเขาค่ะ
หน้าโอเค
ผู้หญิงวะอะไร
ครูหญิงวาดง่าย
มี
อะไร
อะไรคะหมายหนึ่งต้นค่ะผู้หญิงวาดต้นไม้ 1
ต้น
รู๋จะวาดอะไร
ครูเอ๋วาด
ย่าค่ะ
[เพลง]
หญ้า
หญ้าหลายๆต้นอย่า
รูหญิงจะวาดเท่าไหร่ผู้หญิงว่า
ผู้หญิงจะวาดอะไร
อะไรอ่ะกไก่
ไก่ค่ะปิ่งจะวัดดอกไม้ค่ะครูเอ๋
เหมาผู้หญิงจะวัดย่างนิดหน่อยดอกไม้เห้อ
กูยิ่งว่าดอกไม้มีใบไม้ในเอะอะมีมีใบด้วย
ค่ะ
ไปแล้วก็ใบ
ถึงวาดดอกไม้
ดอกไม้ใบไม้ค่ะค่ะครูเอ๋จะวาดอะไร
ครูเอ๋วาด
คุยเปลี่ยนสีได้ไหมเนี่ยพระไม่ได้พระ
อาทิตย์
ขอครูเอว่าถ้าพระอาทิตย์เพื่ออวยว่าพระ
อาทิตย์ค่ะ
ครูหญิง
เชิญค่ะผู้หญิงจะว่านอะไรคะผู้หญิงวาด
ก้อนเมฆค่ะ
ผู้หญิงว่าก้อนแม่พูดกี่ก้อนคะ 4  4 ก้อน
ค่ะ 1223
[เพลง]
1344 กรค่ะผู้หญิงว่าก้อนเมฆ 4 ก้อนใช่
ไหมคะพี่เอ๋จะวาดอะไรคะอ๋ออ๋อมีก้อนเมฆ 4
ก้อนครูเอ๋ว่าฝนตก
ฝนตก
มีฝนตกค่ะค่ะ
ผู้หญิงค่ะผู้หญิงจะวาดอะไรคะกริ๊งวาด
ครูหญิงวาด
อะนกนกบินค่ะครูเอ๋
นกจุ๊ๆๆนกอยู่
- บินค่ะนี่เนาะเอากี่ตัวคะมีนกนึงมี 2
3  4  4  5  5  6  6 ตัวค่ะ
ครูเอ๋
จะว่าน้องจะวาดอะไรคะก็มีเมฆมีฝนตกมีนก
บินค่ะครูเอ๋จะวาด
ภูเขาใช่ไหมคะมีค่ะ
อะไรคะ
น้ำตกค่ะอ๋อน้ำตก
น้ำสมัยน้ำที่ภูเขาแล้วน้ำน้ำตก
[เพลง]
เหววาดน้ำตกค่ะฟ้าหญิงถ้าผู้หญิงจะวาด
อะไรคะอีกว่าต่อครูเอ๋ได้ไหมคะ
ผู้หญิงไว้คิดแล้วอ่ะอาโรหญิงสวาทลำธาร
ค่ะถ้าผู้หญิงว่าลำธารเวลาน้ำตกห่วยน้ำตก
แล้วก็ไหลลงมาเป็นลำธาร
โอเคค่ะนี่เอ๋จะวาดอะไรคะผู้หญิงมีลำธาร
ใช่ไหมครูเอ๋จะวาด
ปลา
ปลาอุ่นลำธารเล็กมากค่ะลำธารเล็กๆมีปลา
ค่ะครูเอ๋วาดปลา
ผู้หญิงจะวาดอะไรคะผู้หญิงวาด
อะไรอ่ะก้อนหินค่ะน้อมันก็นี่ไง
นักเรียนเข้าใจมั้ย
ก่อนหินหินแกรนิตหินบะซอลต์
ผม
ขอดีโอเค
ไหลลำธารมีก้อนหินใหญ่ๆก้อนหินเล็กๆอ๋อ
ตอนหินแข็งก็นี้โอเคค่ะครูเอ๋จะวาดอะไรคะ
ครูเอ๋จะวาดคน
คนนั่งที่ก้อนหิน
คอนคนนั่งบนก้อนหิน
ผู้หญิงจะวัดอะไรคะครูหญิงจะวาด
วิววัดลำธารว่าคนนั่งที่ก้อนหินนะคะอ่า
ครูหญิงจะวาดวัดอะไร
มันจะใหญ่ไปแล้วอ่ะ
ก็
วาดอะไรเหรอวาดเสือค่ะ
ไม่ได้เนาะไม่เอาเสือดีกว่าเอ้ากูหญิง
เปลี่ยนใจล่ะคะผู้หญิงเปลี่ยนใจค่ะ
เปลี่ยนใจเปลี่ยนใจแมวเสือดีกว่าผู้หญิง
ว่าอะไร
ครูหญิงว่าวาด
บ้านค่ะค่ะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงวัดบ้านอ้อ
บ้าน 1 หลังหากผู้หญิงบ้างวัดบ้านใช่ไหม
คะเขาเองว่านอะไรดีจะวาดอะไรอ๋อมีบ้านครู
เอ๋วาดตุ่มน้ำ
ตุ่มแล้วก็มีน้ำ
ด้วยวะตุ่มน้ำใกล้บ้าน
แต่ถ้าผู้หญิงจะว่าอะไรคะ
ครูหญิงจะวาด
ผู้หญิงว่าต้นไม้อีกแล้ว
ใช่แต่อันนี้เป็นต้นมะม่วงค่ะอ๋อ
ผู้หญิงว่าต้นมะม่วงนะคะม่วงรู๋จะวาดอะไร
มากอ๋อมีบ้านใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋ว่าวาด
คู๋ว่าคอกค่ะ
คอบอยู่ใกล้ๆบ้าน
ชายครูเอ๋วาดคอ
[เพลง]
วาดข้อ
มีล้ออยู่ที่นี่ถ้ากูเองวัดคลอบ
ผู้หญิงจะวัดอะไร
ครูหญิงวาดอันนี้กูเห็นมีข้อเครื่องไหมคะ
ไปค่ะ
ผู้หญิงวันอะไรผู้หญิงวัดแกะค่ะแกะอยู่ใน
คอกม้า
แต่จะร้องยังไงนะคะแด่แบบๆ
อ่ะอ๋อแกะแกะผู้หญิงนะสงสารว่า 1 ตัวตัว
อยู่ในคอกค่ะผู้หญิงให้เป็นแก่ครูเอ๋จะ
วาดอะไร
แกะราะแบบาแรมยูใช่ไหมอ่าไอศครูเอ๋วว่า
ต.ค
เอา
งูงู
ลืมเลื่อยงูเลื้อยเลื้อยมาที่คอกแกะ
AF
ผู้หญิงจะว่าอะไร
ครูหญิงว่าคนกับผู้ชาย
มีขามีแขนมีแขนแล้วก็มีไม้
มีไม้มาตีงูค่ะโอ้โห
เพลงโอ้เลยเหรอคะใช่ค่ะอ่ะครูเอ๋จะวาด
อะไรครูเอ๋ว่างอะไรดีดีครูหญิงปีงูไปแล้ว
อ่าอ่ะ
คือตัว a อ่ะอ๋อใกล้ๆบ้านครูเอ๋ว่าวาด
วาด
แปลงผักค่ะโห
แปลงผักอันนี้มีผักสลัด
ผัดสลัดค่ะค่ะ
[เพลง]
ครูจะวัดอะไร
ครูหญิงจะวาด
แม่น้ำค่ะ
มีลำธารมีแม่น้ำ
ตายค่ะมันลบนิดเดียวไม่ได้เหรอคะเนี่ยไม่
เป็นไรไม่ต้องลบก็ได้ค่ะอ่าโอเคคุยถึงจะ
วาดแม่น้ำค่ะแม่น้ำแม่น้ำแม่น้ำใหญ่ๆๆ
ถ้าเจ้มีแม่น้ำใช่ไหมรู๋จะวัดอะไร
ครูเอ๋จะวัดหรือเรือค่ะ
เรือ
[เพลง]
นักเรียนเห็นเรือครูเอ๋ไหม
เลขเครือราคาเรือนี้โอเค
วาดเรือป่ะ
ครูหญิงวาดคน
พี่แต่วาดอย่างที่ไหนค่ะครูหญิงคนที่นี่
ค่ะ
คนแล้วก็
ทำอะไรเธอพายเรือค่ะคนขายเองเรือราคาได้
ครูเอ๋จะวาดอะไรคะอ๋อมีเรือคนพายเรือครู
เอกจะวาด
ศาลา
ศาลานะคะ
ศาลามีเก้าอี้
นาง
ศาลา
ศาลาริมน้ำ
ถ.
เอกวาดศาลาริมน้ำ
ค่ะผู้หญิงจะวาดอะไรคะครูหญิงจะวาด
อะไร
ตั้งนะคะจะวาดโต๊ะอุ้ย
วัดได้แวะผู้หญิง
ให้ได้แต่ว่าโต๊ะค่ะโต๊ะมีขากี่ขาโต๊ะมี
ขา 4 ขาค่ะโต๊ะอยู่ใกล้กับศาลาริมน้ำค่ะ
รู้เหรอจะวาดอะไร
ครูเอ๋จะว่านอะไรดี
โอเคครูเอ๋จะวาดวาดวาดอะไรดี
ครูเอ๋วาด
อะไรคะครูเอ๋
มันคืออะไร
มันคือ
เสาไฟฟ้าขอ
ซื้อหนี้
อ้าคู๋ว่าต.คมีไฟฟ้า
ป
มีไฟ
นี้ไปเข้าบ้านค่ะอ๋อ
ครูหญิงจะวัดอะไรคะผู้หญิงจะว่าเก้าอี้
สาคู
ผู้หญิงวาดเก้าอี้เหรอคะตกแล้วบ้านกูเอง
ไม่ว่าโจอี้
นักเรียนมองเห็นไหมวันเล็กให้มันเล็กเรา
เจ้าอิใหญ่เก้าอี้
เก้าอี้ 2 ตัวอยู่ใกล้ๆโต๊ะค่ะโอเค
รู๋จะวาดอะไรคะครูเอ๋จะวาดแก้วค่ะ
อุ้ยแก้ว
มีเพื่อน
แก้ว
แก้วไวน์
โอโห้
แก้ววางอยู่บนโต๊ะแก้วแค่วายวางบนโต๊ะ
โอเคหน้ากูเห็นลบขยายก่อนนะค่ะ
ครูหญิงสะวาดรวัดอะไรคะ
ครูหญิงจะวาดอะไรดีคะ
อะไรมีเสาไฟมีบ้านมีต้นไม้มีข้อ
มีแก๊สแล้วมีแก้วครูหญิงจะวาดกุ้งที่แม่
น้ำค่ะคู๋นักเรียนจะเห็นกุ้งไหมเห็นไหม
ไม่รู้หนูไม่แน่ใจเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงจะเอาขึ้น
มาให้ดูนะคะอันนี้นะ
ผู้หญิงมันเป็นเอเลี่ยนเฮ้ยเฮ้ยถึงวัดยาก
ไงนี่ค่ะอันนี้คือกุ้ง
กุ้งกูหญิงผู้หญิงคู๋ช่วยไหมได้ค่ะครูเอ๋
ด้วยว่ากุ้งให้กูยืมหน่อยค่ะผู้หญิง -
กุ้งก่อนรบกุ้งใหญ่ๆออก
โอเคกุ้ง
กุ้งอยู่ในแม่น้ำ
จ้าใช่ค่ะ
โอเคกุ้ง
ส้มกุ้งได้ไหมค่ะได้ค่ะได้ค่ะได้นะคะคุณ
รบพุ่งใหญ่ๆก่อน
ผู้หญิงวะกุ้งใช่ไหมใจกุ้งในมีน้ำครูเอ๋
จะวาดอะไรคะคู๋ว่า
กูเองว่าวันนี้
อะไรคะ
ครูเอ๋วาดข่อยถ้าโต๋โต๋หอยธาตุ
ถึงเดินช้า
ๆ
ใช่ค่ะครูหินจะวาดอะไรผู้หญิงอยากว่าจะ
ว่ามันเล็กจังก็ตั้งบนผู้หญิงผู้หญิงจะ
ว่าตรงนี้
อันนี้เป็นต้นไม้อีกหนึ่งต้นแต่ไม่ใช่
สิ่งที่คุณหญิงจะว่านะคะไม่ใช่ครูเอง
ผู้หญิงต้นไม้มากๆใช่แล้วก็ที่นี่ค่ะมิ
เปรง
แต่ถ้าโหคนตายเดินเดินไปนอนใกล้ๆภูเขาหรอ
คะ I ค่ะ
งูเปรย์มีเปลนอน
ครูเอ๋จะว่าอะไร
ครูเอกวาดดาวมี
ไว้ว่าดาวอะไรก็ได้เลย
ได้หรอดาวเจอ
กู a วัดพระอาทิตย์กำลังตกใช่ไหมคะฟ้า
สิทธิ์กำลังตกไปวัดดาวดาว 1 ดวงเหรอคะครู
เอ๋ 2 ดวงก็ได้ค่ะอ่า
ดาวสองดวง
ครูหญิงว่าว่านอะไรคะแต่เมื่อคุยมีดาว
แล้วนะคะผู้หญิง 4 พระจันทร์พระ
จันทร์ที่ดวงจันทร์กำลังขึ้นค่ะดวง
อาทิตย์ตกดวงจันทร์ขึ้นมานี้
ครูเอ๋จะวาดอะไรคะอ๋อครูเอ๋ว่าน
บ้านอะไรดี
วาดว่าอ๋อคู๋ว่า
วาดถังน้ำ
เล็กๆโอเคไหมโอเคค่ะ
ถังน้ำ
อาบน้ำอยู่ใกล้ๆตุ่มน้ำคายมะค่ะมีขังน้ำ
อ่ะอ่า
สำหรับตักน้ำและก็หิ้ว
คิวหนาวค่ะผู้หญิงจะวาดอะไรคะ
มีรูหญิงสะวาดมีอะไรให้ผู้หญิงว่าอีกไหม
คะ
มีเยอะ
ครูหญิงวาด
นี้มีบ้านใช่ไหมคะคุณหญิงว่า
วาดอ่ะอะไร
วาดหมาค่ะ
หนึ่งสองสามสี่หมาผู้หญิงหมาหรือเอเลี่ยน
ฟ้ากะ
หมาหมาเขายังไงคะคงห่วงๆฮงฮงฮง
คุณครูหญิงเองอะไรครูหญิงวาด
เป็ดค่ะผู้หญิงได้มั้ยเนี่ย
รักเจ้ากะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงว่าข้างบนก็ได้
ให้เป็ดยังไม่ลงน้ำก็ได้นักว่าเป็ดว่าย
น้ำ
เป็ดก้าบก้าบก้าบนะคะเป็ดค่ะเป็ดว่ายน้ำ
ครูเอ๋จะวาดอะไร
มีว่างอะไรดีว่าไรอ๋อ
เดี๋ยวนะครูเอ๋ว่าวาดอะไรดีอ้ะนักเรียนกู
ไอ้ว่านอะไรแต่ว่าอะไร
ว่าไหว้ฉันของแล้วนะแต่ว่าอะไรกูเองๆใจ
เย็นๆใจเย็นๆกูเอ๋ว่าต้นหมอเขาโพด
อิอิ
ขอ
ให้ต้นข้าวโพดมีข้าวโพดโพดแล้วก็
ราคา
ข้าวโพดนักเรียนอันนี้นะเขาโพดคุยขยายค่ะ
ข้าวโพดหา
ค่ะเหมือนมั้ยเหมือนต้นนั้นเหมือนๆก็พูด
โอเคนะอะไรลบก่อนค่ะ
ลบๆ
ผู้หญิงเจ้าหญิงอะไรครูหญิงจะวาด
อะไร
ถ้าอะไรเลยค่ะครูเอ๋
อุ้ยทำไมถนนติดกับเปรย์
นี่ไงถนนจะได้ไปเปรย์ได้ถนนถนนถนนถนนมี
นี้ขนนและเดินๆไปนอนที่เปรย์ผู้หญิงว่า
ถนนค่ะครูเอ๋จะว่างอะไร
ครูเอ๋ไปแล้วกูเอ๋หมดและอีกหนึ่ง
โอเค
อาจครูเอ๋วาด
อะไรคะ
สะพาน
สะพานข้ามลำธาร
สะพานข้ามลำธารค่ะหน้าผู้หญิงว่ามีอะไร
หมดแล้วใช่ไหมกูเองหมดเวลาแล้วหรอหมดเวลา
แล้วอ๋ออ๋อเหรอ
ชายค่ะเวลาหรอกหมดแล้ววันนี้ครูหญิงกับ
ครูเอ๋ผู้วาดมากๆค่ะน้องนักเรียนเอามือ
จับหัว
อะไรไม่รู้นะคะทรายค่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้ก็หมด
เวลาแล้วน้องครูหญิงกับครูเอ๋ก็ต้องไป
ก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันนะคะสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย